so if you've noticed that some episodes
and scenes from your favorite shows have
kind of been disappearing lately you're
not losing your mind it's really
happening so I decided to look for some
that have been banned in different
countries
there's a great episode of friends that
features a lesbian wedding wanna guess
what the app is called you nailed it the
one with the monkey butler I'm kidding
it's the one with the lesbian wedding it
was first aired as the 11th episode of
season two meaning it aired in 1996 so
if you're up on your history you know
that it was actually pretty
groundbreaking it was the first time a
lesbian wedding had been shown on the
air in fact in the episode Ross's ex
Carol marries her fiance Susan and Not
only was it important to the storyline
of the show it was culturally important
too Jane sibet who played Carol talked
about how she met a man at an award
ceremony who pointed out how inspiring
the wedding was he told her if he hadn't
seen that episode and thought of the two
characters as Role Models he likely
wouldn't be around into his adulthood
however not everyone saw this scene as
inspiring for starters it was banned in
several countries around the world not
super surprising considering how many
places there still are where it's
illegal to be gay but it was also banned
in certain areas of the U.S like parts
of Texas and Ohio and of course for the
rest of the country this scene aired and
shocked the world was still there the
next day producer Marta Kaufman said NBC
was like super nervous their phone lines
were going to be jammed from all the
people calling to complain they put 104
people on the phones just that evening
but they literally got two phone calls
of complaint whoops speaking of whether
the world will be here tomorrow HBO's
Last of Us is a monster hit about a
post-apocalyptic world and based on the
popular video game of the same name and
there's a moment in episode 7 that kind
of rocked everybody that was of course
the kiss between Ellie and Riley it was
a really cool and touching scene and one
that some parts of the world saw a
really confusing version of the orbit
Showtime Network or OSN is a company
that delivers content to much of the
Middle East and North Africa region and
while they didn't take down the whole
episode especially since it's a global
sensation and they don't want to lose
viewers they did make a rather awkward
cut but in the middle of the moment we
see Ellie and Riley like super close and
then suddenly Ellie apologizes I'm sorry
so unless she had too much of the bean
casserole for lunch that day it was
probably pretty clear she was
apologizing for something that got cut
of course viewers in other parts of the
world know that it was the very brief
kiss that was taken out it's now 27
years after the Friends app and
apparently the notion of two women
kissing is still causing major
malfunctions in some parts of the world
but don't worry there are a lot of
non-lesbian Kiss related Reasons Why
episodes or scenes have been banned
abroad what do you mean for example in
the UK the issue of the troubles in
Northern Ireland has been a pretty
touchy subject for a long time so when
Star Trek the Next Generation mentioned
that Ireland had at one point been
reunified after a quote successful
terrorist campaign is an effective way
to promote political change
yes it can be things got a little
awkward the implication was basically
that Ireland and Northern Ireland had at
some point in the future reunited and it
was because Northern Ireland had
violently terrorized the English to win
back Freedom not to get too into the
weeds with the political and religious
overtones of that yes I'm aware of them
I think that kind of video y'all but
let's just say it's not a statement that
was ever going to go over great in
England so the BBC just up and banned
the episode so if you were surprised to
hear about a banned episode of a Sci-Fi
series you're gonna spit out your water
when I tell you there was an episode of
Sesame Street that had the same fate and
because they also talked about the
troubles in Northern Ireland okay that
last part not so much but there was a
Sesame Street app that was deemed a
little too intense it featured Margaret
Hamilton which might not be a name that
rings a bell how about the name the
Wicked Witch of the West I'll get you my
pretty yup Hamilton played that
green-faced Nightmare and did an
incredible job with it but let's be on
we all had at least one wicked witch
nightmare when we were kids right I mean
the laugh alone will send a shiver down
my spine
the crazy thing is that she was a guest
on Sesame Street I've made it rain a
star always and Missy more than 40 years
after the Wizard of Oz came out and yet
when she suddenly turned into her
Infamous witch character things got real
maybe for you PBS quickly banned the
episode claiming it was just flat out
too scary for little kids they tried to
salvage it holding test screenings for
focus groups and such you know just in
case they had to overreact it but even
after that they were still like yeah
let's just go with the giant talking
bird and the anteater elephant hybrid
because those things are way less scary
to try to help kids not be as scared of
the wicked witch Hamilton even once
appeared on an episode of Mr Rogers
Neighborhood she appeared in costume
minus the green face paint and had a
lovely discussion with Rogers about the
character and the power of Make-Believe
although it didn't help because I like
many out there still have the nightmares
now Margaret Hamilton and green face
might have been scary but things get a
lot more dicey when it comes to darker
shades of face paint for the past few
decades the practice of blackface has
been rightfully called out more and more
as being well not at all okay this got
amped up during the black lives matter
movement that gained traction during
2020. because of that there have been a
bunch of episodes of comedies that have
been retroactively banned from airing
streamers like Netflix and Hulu have
gone back through their catalog to find
instances of it happening and then
removed those episodes oh my God okay
it's happening everybody stay calm
in some instances they removed a scene
or two and in others they pulled full
episodes for example four episodes of 30
Rock were removed and three because they
featured White characters in blackface
makeup In fairness the blackface and
modern comedies is usually meant either
as a silly device like in one of the 30
rocks where Jenna Maroney and Tracy
Jordan swap identities to settle a bet
or to mock the act of blackface itself
for example Jon Hamm appeared in
blackface in a 30 Rock episode because
they were making fun of an actual racist
show from back in the day Amos and Andy
but those nuances don't really cut it
these days and to her credit Tina Fey
made a statement in support of the band
the same is true with a few episodes of
Scrubs which contain some overt
blackface moments in that case Show
creator and producer Bill Lawrence
preemptively went to Hulu and was like
yeah so You're Gonna Wanna ban a few of
our episodes too I took the liberty of
writing them down for you and Hulu went
along with that plan other popular
comedies Like It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia and the office had similar
issues with a few of their episodes
which still remained banned from their
respective streamers even the seemingly
tame stylings of The Golden Girls joined
the party with an episode called mixed
blessings being banned from Hulu in it
Rose and Blanche are wearing mud masks
on their faces they're introduced to a
black character and the joke is that
they're mistakenly thought to be wearing
blackface this is another example where
the humor comes from the fact that
blackface is inherently wrong and oddly
enough if they had just had mud masks on
and a beauty salon setting and the scene
was about something totes different then
it wouldn't have been an issue but as
they say context is everything now what
are you what do you say we all join him
okay I'm gonna go pop on The Wizard of
Oz just to prove I can watch it without
having nightmares
bound to finally not happen right and
Mighty I don't know she's just so wicked
anyway if you can think of some other
episodes or scenes that got banned
around the world or in the US what do
you think pop them in the comments
foreign